oh sure I'd love to know about a 20% off
deal I'm getting Bath and Beyond in the
middle of the day oh and a three-day
sale Raymour and Flanigan definitely
[Music]
when it comes to unwanted messages your
text message list is your new email
inbox except there's no spam button or
promotions filter but there are a few
things you can do about the unwanted
messages number one stop the marketing
texts these often come from retailers
you have shopped at you may even have
agreed to them legit marketing messages
will often say something like text and
to stop do that and if you have an
account with the retailer you can go to
the website and turn off mobile
promotions number two stop the spam if
you get a spam message like something
for a fake sale or free money block the
sender do not reply to the message do
not click on links from people you don't
know some of it can be dangerous do
report messages that come from a phone
number to your carrier on the iPhone
hold down on the message then select
more than the forward button and in the
to field type spam or 7 7 to 6 and send
I wonder if there's a 50% sale right now
not
[Music]